[Applause]
rami malek and nicole kidman reunite
after the hilariously awkward moment at
the Golden Globes Gigi caught up with
the two on the red carpet at the 24th
annual Critics Choice Awards on Sunday
where they laughed off the viral moments
Nicole Kidman are you guys gonna make up
for that viral moment tonight well we
got another interaction Nicole's the
best and we've been having a laugh about
it together she's she's another one I've
admired for so many years and what are
you gonna do anything else I don't know
I mean it depends if I get on stage out
there today and if she does we'll see
we're really good friends that's why I
just do not feel his hand on my back I
was mortified that so no I loved that
man and he's so gentle and softly spoken
yeah he sent me an email I sent him an
email so we were we were laughing
actually good you're both in a bit of a
bit of a day Rahmi also opened up about
his Globes wins just ride in the high of
the globe win with your lady I'm
guessing how is this last couple days
it's been extraordinary I you know I'm
just I'm thrilled that we got to make
this movie that so many people saw it to
be awarded for it it's it's icing on top
it really is
I'm just riding the wave right now and
I'm enjoying every second of it Michael
you left a question for you are you
tired yet he would ask you I work with
spike numerous times he knows I'll
always ask for an extra take no
[Music]